this thing is up in the sky China's
surveillance balloon is triggering a
diplomatic growl that has prompted U.S
Secretary of State Anthony blinken to
postpone his weekend trip to Beijing
it's an irresponsible act and that the
prc's decision to take this action on
the even by planned visit is detrimental
to the substantive discussions that we
were prepared to have the U.S is
accusing China of violating
international law the balloon is still
hovering over the Skies of the United
States it was first tracked over the
Aleutian Islands near Alaska and
traveled through western Canada and into
the U.S state of Montana where it was
spotted near a military installation
home to some of America's nuclear
missiles I have no idea what this thing
is it seems so Brazen and just so insane
to me that that anyone would even
attempt to just push a balloon over the
sky the Chinese foreign Ministry
acknowledged ownership of the balloon
and expressed regret for the incident
but said it was merely collecting
weather data not intelligence the
Pentagon has its doubts still it says
the balloon is not a threat to anyone on
the ground or planes since it's flying
well above commercial air traffic but
there are questions about why the
Pentagon is allowing the Chinese
surveillance balloon to linger looking
at the potential for debris and the
impact on civilians on the ground or
property damage right now as I mentioned
we assess that it does not pose a risk
to people on the ground as it currently
is traversing the continental United
States that hasn't satisfied Biden's
critics in Congress who believe the U.S
needs to take further action to punish
China you cannot reward the CCP for this
kind of flag violation of our
sovereignty by pretending everything is
business as normal and a grip and grin
session with Xi Jinping as this was
happening would have been a terrible
look for U.S diplomacy the CCP will
continue to push the envelope until we
push back this isn't the first time that
China has launched a spy balloon over
the United States the Pentagon says that
in recent years surveillance balloons
have been spotted over Guam and Hawaii
but in the case of this current balloon
the Pentagon won't say whether or not it
eventually will be shot down only that
it's expected to drift over the United
States for the next couple of days
Kimberly Helk at Al Jazeera the White
House